hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts choosing the right fit
navigating the options for NGS target
enrichment presented by Andrew berry
product marketing manager targeting rich
red New England Biolabs I am Kaylee baka
blah boots and I will be your moderator
for today's event we're delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by labyrinth leverage is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time we want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box that appears on the
screen well answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located on the
promotional port at the bottom center of
your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located on the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming mr.
andrew barrett i will now turn the
presentation over to him hi thanks for
joining today my name is Andrew berry
I'll be talking today about some options
that we have in the marketplace today
for target enrichment and you know
really how to navigate those options in
terms of finding the right fit for the
application that is needed and you know
because this is focused on on human
health we'll be focusing mostly on that
through this presentation in terms of
thinking about targeting Richmond and
where it fits I think it's important to
start with an idea of where we stand
today when with regard to
next-generation sequencing what you're
seeing here is is we you know in the NGS
we see this type of figure a lot and
really what it's showing is the the
accumulation of sequencing data over
time and and how that's changed and you
can see the inflection point that
happened sort of in the mid 2000s 2005
to 2010 where next-generation sequence
was developed and really started to you
know dramatically accelerate the the
amount of data that's been produced
we've compared this in the past to
Moore's law which really you know is
focused on doubling the data amount in
every every two years next generation
sequencing over the past ten years or so
has really outpaced that and and you
know really to the point we're doubling
the amount of sequencing data every
seven months and you know I think we
joke about this sometimes where we talk
about the Moore's law obligatory slide
for NGS presentations but I think it's
important that we actually realized that
we've actually sensitize our selves to
this quite a bit in terms of really
appreciating just how much data and then
how quickly we're changing the amount of
data and accumulating these data over
time so the world's data sequencing data
is doubling every seven months and you
know I think just to put that in
perspective that means that you know
from today in April of 2018 by November
of 2018 we are going to double that
amount of data and have that available
and you know the amount of insight that
we're able to glean from this is really
just scratching the surface and I think
that's an important thing to remember as
we think about you know the application
of really looking at specific subsets of
genomic targets in greater detail and
really trying to understand that so you
know just you know to put that in
perspective a little bit the amount of
data that we have is actually going to
be double in seven months that we have
today and you know thinking about the
different conclusions and hypotheses
that we can test using those data so
what are we trying to do with all of
this I think you know this is sort of a
bit of a joke but you know the
understanding is that you know we want
to basically accumulate all of this
information and started to do some
conclusions about the relationship
between those genomic signatures those
those you know nuances in the genome
that make up the sort of 0.1% of the
differences between us and take that to
the point where we can actually
understand the impact on human health so
you know maybe we're not actually
looking at the inability to find the
cell phone off button or theater but you
know understanding more importantly you
know the underpinnings of disease as it
relates to humans so you know what we've
really seen is you know a lot of
controlled studies where we're at the
point where we're filling up databases
with information relating genotype to
phenotype and trying to draw logical
conclusions about you know not only what
is
Genisys of disease but how did his
disease progress how do resistance
mechanisms work when were undergoing a
treatment for a given disease and how
different individuals respond not only
based off of their
you know inherited genomic makeup but
off of things that they've accumulated
through the course of their lifetime as
well and you know I think the best
analogy that I can give is worth point
now where we're really in the process of
building a library in a universally
accessible library that one can go to to
try to find out the information they
need to be able to cure this and and
what a wonderful time to be alive when
when these data are becoming available
and able to use these and and you know a
lot of the work that's happened in
generating all of this data is really
filling up those those bookshelves right
and filling up those libraries with
books that are a useful information that
are well categorized information that
people can search and be able to use
effectively to really test their
hypotheses and and build new ones
hopefully just a little example as it
relates to target enrichment so one of
the more famous databases of genomic
information is something called the
exome aggregation consortium this has
since been updated to be something
called nomad but what this is is it's a
you know really trying to aggregate the
world's whole exome data which whole
exome data does fall into the category
of target enrichment but we're you know
profiling the entire protein coding
regions of the human genome so these
tend to be somewhere between 30 and 50
million base pairs of coding region that
we're able to select out of the genome
and study in greater detail well you
know this this aggregation of this is an
incredibly powerful tool because
basically what it does is it allows
people to understand varying frequencies
across populations and across
geographies so if there's a rare disease
being studied on one continent they can
actually look at the variants that seem
to be causal for that and try to find
out on a more population wide basis the
frequency of those variants and whether
or not they're associated with any known
cases of a similar similar disease or a
similar phenotype so you know this is
just an example and I did some back of
the napkin calculations on this just to
understand you know based on the
performance of whole exome data so for
these 60,000 humans when we run a whole
exome sequencing we're typically getting
somewhere
between sixty to eighty percent of the
base is actually mapping to those
targeted regions for those regions that
were intending to capture that map to
the protein-coding regions so you know
sixteen eighty percent that means that
twenty to forty percent of those bases
are actually thrown out and thrown into
the bin and you know I think it was is
you know just looking at the data that
we don't use for those types of studies
there's a significant amount of data
that's accumulated and looking at that
relative to our ability to screen
something like brca1 and brca2 which
have you know really well understood
sort of clinical phenotypes that you
know can be associated with that the
amount of data that are in those 60,000
exomes that are in the exact consortium
database if we just took the off target
reads from them you have enough data to
actually screen the entire US female
population for brca1 brca2 so I think
that sort of highlights the importance
of having targeted enrichment solutions
that that really work well and really
are able to you know Zone in on the
regions that were particularly
interested in so we'll spend you know
much of the time today's is really
thinking about the different options
that are available there and how they
how to really choose the best fit for a
given undertaking when we think about
translational research this is actually
the definition from Wikipedia but it
applies findings from basic research
basic science to enhance human health
and well-being it's in a medical
research context it aims to translate
findings and fundamental research into
medical practice and meaningful health
outcomes and I think this fits perfectly
with with where things stand today
regarding the amount of data that's
available but also you know the
application of it and the challenges
that arise from from going from you know
a basic research study where you may
have you know plenty of high quality
materials actually applying this in a
real-world setting where you know
samples that you have may be highly
degraded very low input very little
mouths that are actually able to be used
for analysis and I think also important
is to understand that this is a cyclical
process and that you know the outcome
and the things that are learned as the
outcome of one study are really used to
generate the next tech offices and that
you know we're really standing on the
shoulders of giants and taking all this
information and trying to progress our
understanding and you know as we solve
one problem
it typically opens the door to three or
four more that were
we want to address and I'd like to think
about this in some ways as a funnel
right between the initial discovery of
sort of that Association of you know
variants and genotypes that are
associated with the given phenotype and
then obviously this process for how that
might actually translate into clinical
practice eventually and you know as we
think about the amount of content that's
typically used for that you know that
tends to diminish as well in terms of
you know really looking very broadly and
we see that across the different types
of organizations that are involved in
some of these activities as well as you
know the applications that are being
used for this and then finally the tools
that are being used to actually generate
those data so you know we think about
the different types of organizations and
from a discovery standpoint this tends
to be academic research large
government-funded process projects that
are doing things like population scale
screaming we're looking at lots of
healthy individuals lots of affected
individuals and really trying to do that
as broadly as possible to you know not
miss anything and using tools like whole
genome sequencing RNA sequencing and
whole exome sequencing to fill up those
databases can we think about it from the
translational side it really moves into
things like organizations like hospitals
and in front of suitable companies that
are looking to develop new treatment
plans and you know test out these things
through clinical trial processes and and
actually test those hypotheses to
understand if you know the treatments
that are being developed that are
targeted towards a given genotype are
actually you know impactful and for
those you know seeing things like
comprehensive panels that might include
things that we know have a definite
impact but also some things that will
want to learn something from is kind of
the trend that we see there and then
finally as we move to the real clinical
application of this we're really talking
about hospitals and in you know
diagnostic service labs were really
aimed to return information on a patient
back to a physician this is really where
we want to narrow in the focus of the
type of content that we want to include
you just those things that are going to
be clinically impactful so that's where
we tend to see that that sort of funnel
shape coming into play in terms of
utility I think you know really one of
the primary things to understand is what
am I looking for you know in
understanding the difference between a
germline or somatic variant obviously
very basic but this is gonna impact
the amount of sequence coverage in the
coverage depth that you're going to need
to achieve with a given target Richmond
application so you know whether or not
we're looking at broad scale and
Richmond versus very focused in Richmond
who's going to be included in the study
is it is it the individual itself is it
or is it the probe and plus the parents
and a trio for somatic variant calling
Worth where you know we're not talking
about inherited variants we're talking
about things that are you know really
happening through the course of one's
lifetime it's you know the question is
are you are you sampling a biopsy of a
tumor itself and just looking at that
are you going to have access to a match
normal sample that you can use to really
do some error correction and understand
you know which variants are actually
present in the germline and subtract
those out from your somatic variant
calls and one of the strategies that's
been used there is this idea of having a
panel of normals we're used something
like one of these broad databases like X
AK to use and look at sort of what is
the frequency across the population of
variants that are found and use that as
a way to sort of correct for some of the
noise that is inherently present in NGS
data from from a germline perspective
before looking to understand you know
sort of the genetic basis of things
whole exome sequencing makes a lot of
sense because of the ability to mask
data so you know rather than a
laboratory having to run multiple
different panels to look across
different subsets of genes run the whole
exome you will get sufficient depth of
coverage to be able to call most of the
germline variants from that and then you
know only return back in your report the
things that are being asked for so
rather than running lots of different
tests and in a laboratory you can run a
single test and generate all sorts of
information that might be relevant for
you giving giving even hypothesis test
in terms of the types of variants I
think this is also an important
consideration in terms of the different
technologies that are available so
whether or not you're looking for single
nucleotide variants looking for
insertions or deletions that might be
present also looking at copy number
variation so these are all things that
are going to impact you know which
technology you use for example copy
number variant detection is something
that's relatively easy to do with whole
genome sequencing and even whole exome
sequencing is you but because you need
to understand sort of the baseline
performance of these variants and you
know the baseline
in terms of correlating the number of
reads present for a given sample to a to
a given phenotype understanding you know
that variation is important so you know
whether or not a target enrichment panel
has you know sort of markers present to
look at the baseline across the genome
and not just be looking at a focused
event that might be present so you know
copy number variants also known as copy
number aberrations and then a focal
amplification is a common type of cnv
that's that's detected and in many of
these studies so I think you know
thinking more about the different types
of approaches again there's our Moore's
Law slide show in a slightly different
way but you know even though sequencing
costs have continued to decrease for
oncology applications for things that
are really looking at somatic variant
detection we have to go deeper in terms
of the amount of coverage that's present
so this table that you see there kind of
shows the differences between targeted
sequencing whole exome sequencing and
whole genome sequencing both in terms of
the size that's being actually enriched
for and so you know for targeted
sequencing you know looking at
everything from you know 100 kilobases
or 10 kilobases all the way up to you
know 10 mega bases for whole exome
sequencing typically about 32 although
there's some designs that go up to about
a hundred mega bases and then obviously
whole genome sequencing seeking
sequencing the diploid genome you know
looking at 3 Giga bases and looking at
that it at different coverage depths so
for targeted sequencing because we want
to do somatic radiation we're typically
looking at coverage you know greater
than 500 X so actually getting 500 reads
for every low sigh that's present in
that enriched sample pool exome
sequencing tends to get you about 150 x
depending on on what that is and it's
important to understand that you know
what exactly the deliverable is from for
a whole exome sequencing because it will
impact whether or not you'll be able to
use that for semantic variant detection
whole genome sequencing sort of the
standard is 30x and again this is
typically good enough to understand the
germline variants that are present but
if we want to look at somatic variants
we're going to need to go deeper and
then cost associated with this this is
you know continues to be a dynamic
situation in terms of the cost of
sequencing and the cost of
the sample prep reagents but you know in
terms of all-in costs you know targeted
sequencing typically runs somewhere
between you know two hundred to five
hundred dollars per reaction whole exome
sequencing can range from three hundred
up to about twelve hundred dollars
depending on again the carbon step that
you need to go to and the sequencing
platform that's being used and where
whole genome sequencing you know we're
able to do this including you know sort
of all the data processing for about
fifteen hundred and that continues to
decrease with new sequencers as well so
this continues to be a very fluid
situation and fortunately it seems like
the cost of sequencing continues to
decrease but it also can create some
challenges up front to be able to manage
that the sample volume for that one of
the things that I think comes up a lot
is this question of allele fraction and
look at that means in terms of
sensitivity so you know variant allele
fraction is something that really is
telling us the frequency that a variant
is present which you know for well
characterized truth samples are you know
very well understood but for a clinical
sample you're really trying to get an
estimation of that frequency based off
the data that's available to you which
is typically trying to correlate the
number of observations that you have of
a given variant relative to the total
number of observations that you have for
the wild type but that can change based
off a lot of different factors and I
think it's important to recognize that
it's not just as simple as the number of
reads relating directly to very low
frequency so you know for one thing
tumors are a heterogeneous mixture of
both stromal which is gonna have your
normal genome as well as the tumor cells
and complex genomes and their variants
are present at a wide range of
frequencies so if we're thinking about a
driver and mutation that we're trying to
detect very early in the genesis of
disease from a sort of prognostic
standpoint you know those are present at
very low Leal fractions where as you
know passenger mutations that might be
you know very frequent might come at a
50 percent allele frequency depending on
what they are and then I think further
adding to this is the fact that variants
are typically present and amplified
regions so if we're looking at copy
number variants where we have multiple
copies of a given low side that needs to
be factored into the equation as well
and you know really impacts the depth of
sequencing that is required to be able
to call this reproducibly
and we don't just like to see a variant
once
typically most people like to see a very
impressed and at least ten reads before
they confidently call it option positive
so you know we think about that
calculation it's really a percentage of
the reads calling a variant from you
know the analytical side so that means
that for example if you have 100 reads
and the copy number is equal to 1 if the
variant press is present in 50% of the
reads you'll call that a variant of the
frequency of 0.5 if your copy number
equals 2 that means that you have twice
the opportunity to observe this and if
its present 50% of the reads that just
means that you only have a 25% varying a
little frequency so in effect the higher
the copy number that equals the lower
little fraction and in terms of
understanding the depth of sequencing
that is actually required to call a
specific variant you know I typically
try to think of a simple formula where
you know if you want to get 10 reads per
per variant to be able to call it
confidently you know if you have you
know a 1 percent allele fraction and you
have a hundred reads you know it's
basically going to be present in one out
of every 100 reads so you know you
basically need to be sequencing to about
a thousand X to be able to call that
reproducibly and as we think about
things like you know cell free DNA and
those applications we really want to
push the variants in terms of looking at
these driver mutations early on you know
those tend to be down into the point 1
percent where you really need to get
high depth coverage in order to have
enough times to actually see it because
know you'll only be seeing that variant
and you know point one percent or one at
a thousand reads and if you want to get
10 reads that means you're gonna have to
sequence to a depth of roughly 10,000 X
you know I think further complicating
this is the fact that you have false
positives that arise from you know
really errors that are happening on
about in a biological sense you know
they have to do with things like like
storage so a great example of that is
FFT samples so these tend to be highly
variable in terms of the quality you
know we've seen samples from FFP that
look as good as fresh frozen tissue you
know that could be very old but you know
we're collected properly in a clinical
setting restored properly that looked
very
we've also seen you know recent FFPE
samples that tend to look very poor and
again this is highly dependent on this
specific collection in a specific way
that samples were processed but there
are you know errors that are incurred
through the process of actually fixing
the tissue and actually getting an
embedded and paraffin and we see you
know it's one of the reasons that FFP
tissue is so so stable is that you are
creating cross links so you see you know
lots of protein DNA cross-linking
happening DNA DNA cross links as well as
actual damage where we'll have backbone
breaks and occlude double-stranded
breaks single-stranded nicks as well as
you know just gaps and in terms of the
content that's available and then
there's also sort of other impacts in
turn that will cause errors where you
see things like hydrolysis and base
deamination that'll actually incur
errors into those samples oxidation will
happen where we'll actually get
conversions of specific nucleotides so
in this case from from a deoxy G to a
deoxy T that are going to impact the
sort of noise that's present in your
sequencing data and really you know show
you know the types of you know really
make it hard to call variants accurately
if you have that level of noise and
looking at the false positive versus
true positives and we'll talk a little
bit more about some strategies that can
be undertaken to overcome some of these
a little later in the presentation so
you know in effect what this is gonna do
is those sort of top cross-linking and
breaks are going to reduce the amount of
material that's actually available for
enrichment and then obviously and
actually incurring some of those errors
if we think about the actual process for
going from FFPE so coming from an FFP
block where tissue has been stored and
actually getting that onto a sequencer
you know typically that that that FFP
block is taken into cross sections and
in slice into sections typically you
know that'll undergo some sort of
upfront qualification be that through
some in a normal HD histopathology
potentially immunohistochemistry using
specific antibody labels or fish
analysis to try to you know actually
look at what's the present and do some
actual biomarker discovery on that so
those slides are those sections are
mounted onto
slides and then going through this
process and then you know if we actually
want to get material off of that
somebody actually has to go in and
scrape the the actual tissue off of that
put that into a DNA extraction protocol
go through your target enrichment
library prep process and then finally
get to your next-generation sequencer so
it's not a trivial thing and there's a
lot of steps along the way where things
can happen to the DNA as well which can
you know again diminish the amount of
material that you have present for next
generation sequencing analysis or you
know cause damage that might induce some
false positives into your data talking a
little bit about cell-free DNA workflows
I think this is a very popular topic and
very hot topic because of the potential
of this you know obviously you know
being able to look at DNA that's being
shed by a tumor you know as it's you
know going through metastasis is is you
know it has some great advantages in
terms of its you know much less invasive
than the tissue biopsy especially
depending on where the tumor is again
you know looking at this for sort of
diagnostic prognostic applications you
know if you could have a blood test and
tell you whether you have you know the
potential to to develop a cancer over
time you know the value of that
information is huge and there's a lot of
things happening there are some
commercial tests available that have
been you know gone through sort of CLIA
validation and are available to actually
send your samples through and you know
actually receive a clinical report but a
lot of a lot of this is still in the
research side and really understanding
the capability in the predictive nature
of cell-free DNA and a lot of these are
looking at sort of longitudinal studies
where they look at patients across the
course of tumor progression across you
know treatment with various therapies
and then trying to understand you know
what is happening in terms of you know
if the cells actually in the tumor
actually developing resistance for a
given therapeutic so you know
understanding the nuances and the
presence of cell-free DNA based off of
those is something that is easy to do
again because it's it's non-invasive
important to understand that for
cell-free DNA tends to be present at
very low allele fractions so you know
this is based off the percentage of the
cell-free DNA itself that is derived
from tumor and also the frequency of the
variants that we're trying to detect
being at low frequency and that sort of
0.1 percent is kind of the target for
most of these types of applications the
DNA itself is
very fragmented tends to come at a size
of about 160 base pairs which actually
fits very well with next-generation
sequencing read length and also doesn't
require any fragmentation that can also
lead to some sample loss so you know I
think this is this is a really
interesting area that will continue to
be explored and you know the sort of
clinical application of this is only
going to grow over time and having
having technologies that are able to
really you know push the conversion of
molecules that are taken from blood and
and put that into onto a library
preparation or into target enrichment
onto a sequencer to actually develop the
depth of coverage that we need and to do
that as efficiently as possible because
we want to get to such high sensitivity
low frequency variant allele for
actually calling so if you think here's
a little bit to talk a little bit about
some of the techniques are actually used
to actually you know run Target and
Richmond you know I like to break this
down into sort of two main strategies
and the first being hybridization the
second being implica nor multiplex PCR
and you know I like to separate them
this way and I think that there's a lot
of variants of this that we can we'll
talk about but you know fundamentally I
think there's two separate strategies
for actually enriching the targets that
you're interested in from the ones that
you you aren't and you know breaking it
down between these two I think is an
easy way to sort of bucket the two
different types of technologies so for
hybridization you know really what we're
focused on for the enrichment is
balancing the melting temperature of a
long all of a nucleotide probe or bait
that's going to hybridize completely to
a section of DNA and what we use as
magnetic bead to pulle that town
whereas for amplicon sequencing we're
really relying on amplification of those
targets to generate the enrichment
itself so you know rather than pulling
things away and subtracting the stuff
we're interested in your to making
copies of the DNA which has some issues
that we'll get into a little bit you
know in broad strokes hybridization
based approaches tend to work better for
larger enrichment panels up to whole
exome and beyond that they tend to have
higher sample input requirements and
we'll talk a little bit about
deduplication which is an important
factor when we're trying to predict
allele frequencies detect pairings
for amplicon sequencing you know this
tends to you shorter primer pairs so
there is a melting temperature
dependency and because they're shorter
it tends to be more or less normalized
across than it would be in a longer
Holika nucleotide is he looking across
different targets tends to be have very
short workflow time so it's very simple
way of generating you know libraries
based off the fragments that you're
interested in you know becomes
challenging as you try to scale the
technology though as you get to too many
targets and making sure that primer
interactions aren't happening and
different targets are amplifying evenly
that's where we can run into some issues
there but also tends to have very low
sample input requirements and able to
address you know things down to you know
one five 10 nanograms input to a PCR
because you are using amplification as
and primary mechanism of enrichment so
just to talk a little bit more about
hybridization based in Richmond this is
originally published by newark ii in
2009 but you know in this in this
instance they're using oligonucleotide
bates
in this case synthesized on a microarray
so these are synthesized in this case
these are converted into biotinylated
RNA fragments that are actually
complementary to the DNA that we're
trying to hybridize to in parallel there
we start with genomic DNA that's been
extracted that tends to get cheered
either mechanically or through some
enzymatic fragmentation process and
basically what what is done is there's a
hybridization that takes place over
anywhere from 18 to 70 to 72 hours where
those all of the nucleotide baits are
biotinylated and bound to the targets of
interest and then using a streptavidin
beater pulled away some PCR is performed
again second round of PCR has performed
to actually aleut the the enriched
fragments off of the off of the beads
and then that product is taken on into
next generation sequencing important to
note that a library is made in this
process here where you know you shear
you actually have to ligate your
adapters on there and then you typically
PCR enrich that before you go into the
hybridization mention it tends to be a
longer process which you know has some
issues when you're trying to implement
this in a more clinical setting where
turnaround times
to be shorter or there's a desire to
have short turnaround times and you know
the again these work really well for
large panels you know down to about you
know five mega bases or so beyond their
what we start to lose is some
specificity where we see lots of breeds
that are mapping to our off target
regions will tend to come in and come
along for the ride and make their way
into our sequencing data so you know as
I mentioned you know for a large panel
whole exome you know somewhere between
sixty to eighty percent don't target is
looking very good when you start to get
into more focused panels of down into
the mega base or lower range you know
thirty to forty percent on on target is
actually doing pretty well for this so
you're you enriching for the regions
that you're interested and you're
getting good fold enrichment but there's
a lot of other stuff that come along for
the ride
multiplex PCR is sort of the opposite of
that again it's a very simple process
that uses primers that are specific for
the the regions of interest to actually
amplify up those regions you know
there's a couple different approaches to
this and then people have you know taken
this and you know done lots of
interesting things with it but you know
primarily what this involves is having a
forward and on first primer either
having those primers themselves tailed
with the next generation sequencing
adapter sequence to make that library so
obviously a very simple process or PCR
process where you know PCR takes place
and then you actually go into a location
where you like it those universal
adapters onto the proximal ends of each
of those molecules you know I'd say the
biggest challenge even though it works
very fast and uses little input the
biggest challenge is you know primer
interactions you know having uneven
coverage across the different amplicons
and you know getting tiling across some
regions that may be difficult to design
a primer to PCR duplication is also a
challenge to talk a little bit about
more about that but you know effectively
what you have based on the primer
sequence is a unique start and stop site
so it becomes very difficult to
differentiate between a molecule that is
a true biological replicate and
something that is actually just a PCR
copy that it's gonna you know again
impact our ability to predict variant
allele frequencies and understand you
know the prevalence of mutation in a
given sample there's been lots of
alternative strategies that have been
developed as well so selector probes
our one and this is you know where we
have a probe that's specific to a region
of interest is a circularization and a
in a amplification event that takes
place after that molecular inversion
probes are a useful tool for this as
well you know won't get into too much of
the specifics of these and then you know
multiplex extension ligation is another
example where people have adapted a you
know amplicon like strategy to you know
try to produce better quality data and
you know we see these prevalent in the
marketplace so as a product marketing
manager i am responsible for a product
that fits into this face so this is any
be next direct this is a hybridization
based approach so it's a little bit
different in the sense that typically
you make a DNA library and then do your
enrichment in this case we enrich
directly off of the genomic DNA so we do
the enrichment first and then take that
in rich material and convert that into
the next generation sequencing library
through a series of enzymatic
modifications it's a single day workflow
I think you know some of the benefits is
that we incorporate an enzymatic removal
of off-target to enhance the specificity
for focus panels and also incorporate
something called the um I are unique
molecule index that we'll talk about a
little bit more that is helpful for
understanding the difference between a
biological replicate molecule and a PCR
replicate molecule so when we think
about the different metrics for target
enrichment I think it's important to
understand what each of these sort of
mean and you know sensitivity and
interest as a sort of disclaimer we're
talking about you know really the the
key metrics as an output of next
generation sequencing not necessarily
related to any sort of an analytical
specificity or sensitivity but you know
we talked about sensitivity we're really
saying you know I like to use the
analogy needle on a haystack
so from a sensitivity standpoint what is
the lowest bearing allele frequency I
can detect in a data set you know a way
to think about that is what is the
smallest needle that I can find in a
haystack and this is you know determined
based off of multiple factors including
false positive variance and presence of
those you know the actual allele
fraction and trying to get to very low
fraction variants as well as you know we
talked about some of the stromal
contamination that can make it difficult
to
all variants based off of the actual
cells that are used as an input into the
assay specificity is obviously important
and I think that it has to do with the
efficient in the efficiency of the
enrichment so you know how efficiently
can I separate my targets from the rest
of the genome or how efficiently can I
separate my needles from the haystack
and you can see that image there we have
a magnificent Edel away you know then
not not coincidental that's how we
actually perform target enrichment using
magnetic beads in many cases our
uniformity is really important so you
know how many targets can I find with
equivalent efficiency in the data set
this is important because it ultimately
dictates how much sequencing is required
so the presence of PCR duplicates will
obviously impact that as you need to you
know sequence past those duplicate
molecules to get to the true biological
molecules any PCR bias where there's
different efficiencies in terms of the
enrichment is going to throw that off it
can be difficult for from you know
balancing based specific baits in a
given panel again you know I think at
the end of the day it comes down to you
know weighing our options and in saying
you know do I need a fast workflow do I
need something that's less expensive
that works for low input DNA has been
specificity for my targets but you know
it's gonna be difficult to scale content
to you know if I need to add genes to my
panel if I need to look at a larger
subset of genes I may be dealing with
poor uniformity across targets and you
know overall a lower quality of data
whereas with hybridization based
enrichment you tend to have higher data
quality and works really well for large
panels but it tends to be longer
workflow it's more expensive tends to
require more input DNA and as you get to
smaller panels can have low specificity
we think about coverage uniformity this
was actually just published from a
publication that came out last month
this is looking at comparing
hybridization based enrichment to
amplicon sequencing so what we're
looking at and the figures on the right
is actually the the uniformity of
coverage and those so the mean target
coverage for the same same panel was
designed both of capture probes as well
as amplicon in Richmond and you know
what we would love to have is you know
as
normalised as possible where we're
getting you know even coverage that's
equivalent to a given value so we'd love
to see the straight horizontal line in
terms of the coverage but what we see
here is is you know for capture probes
for hybridization based enrichment you
tend to have more even enrichment again
because we're selecting those targets
away from the rest of the genome as
opposed to amplifying the targets that
were interested in away from the genome
and you can see the coverage variability
so even in the scale here we you know we
see the coverage in terms of standard
deviation about two hundred and twelve X
where you know when we get into amplicon
sequencing you're talking about
thousands a full difference between
those and you know that is gonna have an
impact on you know what you actually are
able to do in terms of trusting the very
little frequencies you're trying to
predict the fact that it's gonna require
over sequencing so for your you know
high-performing amplicons you're going
to end up sequencing those two into
really high sequencing depths if you
have uneven coverage to get your lower
performing targets up to the minimum
threshold where you can reliably call
variance or frequency that's that's
needed so it's just an important you
know factor to understand as you're
thinking about the strategy to choose
PCR duplication so you know what you see
in that figure on the left those are
integrated in genomics Lehrer plots
looking at coverage profiles for
something that was done with
hybridization based enrichment brushes
amplicon and again one of the benefits
to hybridization based in Richmond is
that you tend to have non-uniform star
and n sites because we're randomly
fragmenting DNA or hybrid Iying
hybridizing a probe that may have a
certain amount of homology through that
actual molecule using that to pull that
down away from the rest of the genome
you're gonna end up with random random
start and stop sites for each of the
reads that you're actually generating
out of your sequencing data whereas for
amplicon because it's based off of
primer design and primer sequences those
amplicon reads are going to have the
exact same start and stop sites again
that makes it difficult to differentiate
between a PCR duplicate and an actual
biological toolkit molecule on the right
I think they're interesting plot there's
is the way that we actually can look at
you know coverage and you know having
non-uniform start and end sites
are important because you know really
allows us to determine the true coverage
that that's present and you know when we
look at this so you know in this plot
what we see is you know any given metric
but but typically what we look at is
unique coverage that would be present
for a given low sigh and really what we
want to be able to do is increase the
amount of sequencing coverage on the
amount of reads that we have and
continue to add new information into
that so in that purple figure you can
see that we can continue to add
sequencing depth to that and actually
find some new things where as you know
in that green that green line there
basically what you have is you've
exhausted the molecules that you have
for next-generation sequencing so you
can keep sequencing but all you're going
to be sequencing is PCR duplicates so
you're not you can continue to add Dex
but you're not really adding that and
the challenge there is that what they
amplify on sequencing typically you
don't know because you really can't
understand what the true duplication
that's happening for a given given a
dataset would be so you really don't
know whether or not you're you can
continue to sequence all you want and
find you know hide depth of coverage but
you may not discover any new parents
that might be present in those samples
one of the strategies that's been
employed to overcome this is this idea
of having any unique molecule identifier
or a unique molecule index and that's
you know again that what that's going to
do is is mark the molecules with it with
a DNA barcode before you amplify so that
you can understand the genesis of each
of your resulting molecules and look
back at that to be able to understand
the duplicates that are present in
addition to that there's some strategies
that are employed that actually utilize
unique molecule indexes to do error
correction and something called
consensus variant calling it just
quickly I think you know understanding
how this works so without the UM I
present basically you know what we have
is two biological replicates of the
molecule copy and copy B we're going to
perform PCR on both of those you know so
what you see in the red is a true
positive variant that's gonna get
perpetuated through that but in that
process of doing PCR amplification
you're also going to acquire some false
positive variants as well and you know
in this situation because we don't know
which of these are wish and those
molecules effectively look the same it's
really difficult to understand which of
the
variants are derived from false
positives or which of these are actually
true positive variants that we actually
would want to include in a dataset if we
take the same situation but now we've
actually tagged each of these molecules
before PCR amplification again we're
going to go through the same process of
amplifying those fragments we're still
going to acquire our false positive
variants that will come into play there
and what we have now is a situation
where you know what you see is we're
able to group those reads by the the
actual umi so that would be a you know
sequence that would be added to the read
itself that would you know allow us to
group these things and call them what we
called read families and look across
those to say okay you know in this
situation I can see that for the the um
I yell the yellow um I basically all
over my all of my DNA molecules are
harboring this this red true positive
snip whereas in the situation where with
that sort of teal um I basically the the
variants that are not present and tend
to be variable across that and we can
identify those ones that are available
variable as being high false positive so
at the end of the day what this is gonna
do is reduce our signal-to-noise ratio
when we're actually calling trying to
call true positive snips it's gonna lead
to higher sensitivity variant calling
and more accurate assessment of variant
allele frequencies and one of the
questions has come up because you know
PCR duplicates have always been you know
viewed as a somewhat negative you know
thing result that will happen from doing
PCR amplification we're now actually
having multiple copies of these
molecules is present because he is
helpful because you can actually use
them to you know derive some useful
information out of that this is a data
set that was produced internally here
but basically looking at the number of
reads in terms of the consensus depth so
how many of each read each each
sequencing degree do we keep so you can
see that on the x-axis you know as we go
up to from one to three you can see a
dramatic impact in terms of the error
rate or the phred score this is on the
Fred score scale but dramatic impact on
the error rate that's present and in
terms of the quality of those reads so
we're able to get up to a fret 50 you
know very quickly where you
down into the sort of friend for a 30
range as we do that so that means that
you know again PCR duplicates or
duplicates in general or a friend as
long as we can identify them as PCR
duplicates and use them in conjunction
with the UM eyes to be able to do this
type of consensus variant colleague or
error correction and I do think this is
you know one of the things that will
ultimately help target enrichment
strategies you know really take it to
the next level and be able to be able to
look at really low Leal fraction
variants that might be present in some
of these samples again as we push from
diagnostic into prognostic type
applications be able to really push the
depth of sequencing push the conversion
of those molecules so we can actually
make sure that our reads are getting to
you know the datasets themselves are
rich enough that we can actually derive
some of this really useful information
from so I think you know just in
conclusion you know there's really a lot
of considerations that need to be taken
into account as you're deciding you know
what the right fit is in terms of a
technology for a given application
understanding the goal of the study are
we looking for somatic variants were
looking for germline variants do we need
to call a copy number variance with this
sensitivity is huge because it's a
direct function of how much sequence
depth you need to get out of your actual
sample and you know understanding the
percentage of variant allele frequencies
that you need to get down to in terms of
sensitivity input material as we
discussed can be you know highly
variable but understanding not just the
type of material but also the amount of
material that's gonna be available for
your study and also the panel itself how
big is the panel how many genes do you
want to include are there intronic
regions that can have interesting you
know different challenges that might be
saw associated with homology to
repetitive elements in the genome versus
you know looking for just the coding
regions in those exonic regions you know
how many samples how scalable is my
technology can I run this across you
know thousands of patient samples or you
know is this something that I really
just want to run a handful of things on
you know what is the turnaround time for
the workflow how fast do I need to be
able to return data out of this workflow
and you know how easily can i aughtta
mate this how easily can a scale this
technology if I do need to implement it
into routine practice so you know again
it's it's you know there's no single
technology and I think that it really
covers the gamut of what people need to
accomplish with
target Richmond but it's clear that you
know additional development does need to
continue to take place and this is an
active area where you know continuing to
innovate continuing to push the
boundaries of what's possible is really
important to be able to recognize some
of the benefits from all this wonderful
genomic data that's being developed and
generated through through many
organizations around the world so with
that I'll thank you and I think we'll
move on to the Q&A section of the
webinar Thank You mr. Berry for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask the question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions to be a time for
let's get started our first question is
what applications are there for target
enrichment outside of translational
research that's a great question I think
you know there is obviously focus this
presentation was on sort of human health
and how that applies there but target
Richmond is being employed across
industries and everything from you know
playing genotyping crop development
things like food testing you know
understanding you know different
breeding strategies for different
organisms and cattle and things like
that
so there's there's lots of different
applications for which target enrichment
is being applied and you know some of
these will have different requirements
based off of the needs of a specific
application but you know I think there's
you know it's as much as the imagination
can take it in terms of you know
fundamentally needing to look at the
genome of an organism and look at
regions of that in greater detail than
you would by just doing whole genome
sequencing great our second question
says how many base pairs long should a
um IV so yeah the question about how
long a unique molecule index you know
really this is gonna have to do with the
the size so the operating size of BMI so
you know if we think about it very
simply you know it's a random sequence
that gets appended to each of those
molecules so you know how long
is going to impact the number of
available um eyes that are there you
know some studies have shown that that
having a um I greater than eight base
pairs is useful I know in our technology
to be next direct it's a twelve base
pair um I so--that's ends up being you
know four to the twelfth which is just
under seventeen million available but
you know most of the things that I've
read really recommend having you in mind
that's about you know greater than eight
base pairs long okay our next question
says how much DNA can you get from FFPE
yeah so FFP tissue that we talked about
a bunch it's a pretty common sample type
for clinical workflows you know
obviously it allows things to be
preserved the actual amount of DNA that
you're going to get out of that can be
highly variable
you know based off of obviously the
biopsy itself and the amount of tissue
that was embedded is gonna impact that
but also you know how it's being
utilized whether or not you're taking a
section how big that section is if
you're doing a punch where you're
actually looking longitudinally through
that section you know that could that is
gonna impact that so you know it can be
anywhere from a few nanograms 10
nanograms have been put to several
hundred nanograms if you actually have a
whole block available so it really does
you know vary quite widely but somewhere
between 10 and 100 nanograms is
typically what we see for for dname but
coming out of a tissue we have time for
one more question and this one says what
are the common sources of error in
target enrichment data oh so you know
can come from different places obviously
we talked about some of the errors that
can be incurred during the the sample
processing itself so you know through
you know fixation processes or
extraction processes where you know
potentially treated but with harmful
chemicals that can actually do some you
know base pair changes to the actual DNA
as well as impact that back bone itself
also PCR amplification is another source
of error where you know as you're doing
PCR and making copies of things it's not
always perfect so you're gonna incur
some level of errors that'll happen
there you know also through many of the
hybridization based enrichments when
we're doing the wash is to remove off
target they tend to be some you know
relatively harsh chemicals that can be
used there that can also induce some
some base changes and cause error in
your sequencing data then finally on the
sequencers themselves right so
sequencers have inherent error rates and
some of that comes from the sequencing
process itself some of that comes from a
clonal amplification that'll take place
before you actually get onto your
sequencers so you know all along the way
we're doing things and as much as we can
do it actually preserve the integrity of
that start and DNA sample by not
subjecting it to multiple rounds of PCR
hopefully you know getting things from
you know clinical collection as quickly
as possible is only gonna help reduce
those errors that might depress man
ingest data I would like to once again
thank mr. berry for his presentation I
would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through July 2018 you'll receive an
email from labyrinths letting you know
when the subcraft will be available for
replay please show that announcement
with your colleagues the main miss
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye